BACK.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS REPORTEDLY
PUTTING A STAFF TOGETHER TO FEND
OFF POTENTIAL REPUBLICAN LED
PROBES.
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON
PROBES, TWO STAFFERS ARE GETTING
PAID A QUARTER OF A MILLION
DOLLARS TO OVERSEE RESPONSES TO
SUBPOENAS AND RESPOND TO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
THE MEDIA IS STILL TRYING TO
SPIN THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY
AFTER REPORTS SURFACE THAT HAD
HUNTER WOULD FACE CRIMINAL
CHARGES AND OPINION PIECE IN
POLITICO ARGUES IT WILL HELP
BIDEN.
I WANT TO GO TO THIS PARTICULAR
QUOTE IF WE CAN PUT THAT UP.
THAT JACK SCHAFER THAT WAS IN
POLITICO AND THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD AFTER SHAKING OFF NATURAL
PARENTAL GLOOM ALLOW HIMSELF A
MOMENT TO CELEBRATE THE
POLITICAL GAIN HE STANDS TO REAP
IN THE WAKE OF A HUNTER BIDEN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE MISFORTUNE.
HUNTER BIDEN INDICTMENT AND
PROSECUTION WOULD DEMONSTRATE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT IS SUCH AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
OR I GUESS A STATEMENT, JACKI,
THIS WOULD NORMALLY BE A BOMB
SHELL REPORT WITH HUNTER BIDEN
AND NOT MUCH LIGHT WITH THE
MEDIA AND THEY'RE RAMPING UP AND
PAY STAFF TO DEFEND THE
PRESIDENT AND HUNTER BIDE AND A
LOT OF SUBPOENAS WILL BE AROUND
HUNTER BIDE AND IS IT NORMAL FOR
THE PRESS TO IGNORE SUCH BOMB
SHELL ALLEGATIONS THAT WE'RE
SEEING WITH A POTENTIAL
INDICTMENT?
JACKIE: WE'VE SEEN THIS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WHERE LEFT MEDIA
TURNS THE OTHER WAY AND IGNORES
IT'S HAPPENING.
WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT THE HUNTER
BIDEN LAPTOP FOR SO LONG AND
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT TILL A GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATION AND FINALLY SOME
REPORTERS WALKED IT BACK AND
SAID, WE'LLING ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
IS ACTUALLY REAL.
BUT THERE'S SO MANY HERE TO DIG
INTO.
THE FACT THEY'RE PAYING STAFFERS
TO DO DAMAGE CONTROL ESSENTIALLY
ON THIS.
THAT'S OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS
GOING TO THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE JACK
SCHAFER COMMENT, A HUNTER BIDEN
INDICTMENT AND PROSECUTION
INDICTMENT WOULD DEMONSTRATE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IF THE WASHINGTON POST ARTICLE
IS TRUE AND CHARGES ARE BROUGHT,
THEY'D THEY'D DECLARE INCOME
FROM FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS
AND HE WAS A DRUG ADDICT ON A
GUN APPLICATION.
WHAT ABOUT THE BUSINESS DEALS
AND WHAT TRANSACTIONS TOOK PLACE
IN CHINA AND UKRAINE AND WHAT
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
INVOLVEMENT.
THIS IS NOT A WIN FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IF IT GOES
FORWARD LIKE THIS.
LARA: BUT THAT'S THE -- THE
WHOLE THING HERE I FIND SO
ALARMING IS THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE SAID THIS, THIS IS WHAT
THEY THINK THE TACTIC IS, IT IS
THESE MINIMAL CHARGES RELATIVE
TO THESE BIGGER ISSUES OBVIOUSLY
AND THESE HUGE QUESTIONS WITH
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATIONS,
JACKI, LIKE YOU JUST SAID.
PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE THIS
AS A BIG WIN.
OH, WE'VE GOT THE HUNTER BIDEN
SITUATION ALL WRAPPED UP BECAUSE
LIKELY IF THIS IS ALL HE'S FACES
IS TAX CRIMES AND ILLEGAL GUN,
THERE'LL BE A PLEA DEAL AND WE
CAN JUST SAY WELL THIS MATTER IS
OVER AND LET'S NOT WORRY ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN ANYMORE.
LARA: TO THAT POINT, CAN WE PLAY
THAT TRUMP SONG.
>> WE DON'T WANT BAD STUFF TO
HAPPEN BUT THEY'RE LEEKING A
COUPLE -- LEAKING A COUPLE OF
MINOR CHARGING COMPARED TO THE
MAJOR CHARGES THEY COULD BE AND
THAT'S UP TO THEM.
BUT ARE THEY ACTUALLY GOING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND HOLD THE
BIDENS ACCOUNTABLE OR IS THIS
JUST A CHARADE AND EXCUSE TO
CONTINUE TARGETING ME AND OUR
MOVEMENT OF MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN AND AMERICA FIRST?
I DON'T KNOW.
LARA: NOW, SEAN, I THINK HE MADE
A REALLY GREAT POINT THERE
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE QUESTIONING THAT IT'S
TAKEN SO LONG IN THIS
INVESTIGATION, CHARGES HASN'T
BEEN BROUGHT YET AND NOW YOU GOT
SOME ON THE LEFT SAYING, YEAH,
MAYBE THIS WOULD BE A GOOD
THING.
COULD IT BE A HIDDEN LANGUAGE
THEY'RE USING?
MAYBE THIS WOULD BE A GOOD THING
IF THEY'D INDICT HUNTER BIDE AND
GO AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP SO THEN
THEY CAN SAY, THIS ISN'T
POLITICAL.
WE WENT AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
SON AND GOT INTEGRITY IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SEAN: THE PROBLEM IS THEY'RE
GOING TO GUARDRAIL THESE CHARGES
AND TAX CRIMES OR GUN CRIME,
THEY'LL KEEP IT AWAY FROM JOE
BIDEN HIMSELF.
THAT WOULD BE THE INTENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHEN THEY
CHARGE HUNTER BIDEN IF THEY DO
CHARGE HIM.
BUT GOING BACK TO REPUBLICANS,
YOU DON'T WANT TO DANCE ON A
POWERFUL POLITICIAN'S SON WHO IS
A DRUG ADDICT, HE'S AN AMATEUR
PORN STAR, HE'S COMMITTED
CRIMES.
IT'S EMBARRASSING BUT THAT'S BAD
POLITICS.
THE REASON THIS IS A BIG STORY
IS THAT HUNTER BIDEN IS TIED TO
JOE BIDEN AND WE COULD NOT HAVE
IN THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS
INVESTIGATING THIS ISSUE UNLESS
IT TIED INTO THE PRESIDENT AND
YOUR POINT THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
MAKING MONEY OFF HUNTER BIDEN'S
FOREIGN DEALINGS, WHICH MEANS
HE'S SPRUE MUSED AND REPUBLICANS
HAVE TO -- COMPROMISED AND THE
WHITE HOUSE WILL PUSH BACK HARD
AND REPUBLICANS HAVE TO SUBPOENA
DOCUMENTS AND WITNESSES, THEY
HAVE TO HOLD THE ADMINISTRATION
IN CON AT THE PRESENT TIME IF
THEY DON'T -- CONTEMPT IF THEY
DON'T COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENAS
AND IF THAT HAPPENS, WE HAVE TO
PROSECUTE.
WE'LL SEE HOW PURE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS TO SEE IF THEY'LL
PROSECUTE DEMOCRATS THAT DON'T
COMPLY WITH THE HOUSE LIKE THEY
DID WITH REPUBLICANS WHO DIDN'T
COMPLY WITH THE JANUARY 6
INVESTIGATION.
JACKIE: THAT'S RIGHT.
GIANNO: LARA, HAS THE DOJ MADE
ANYMORE MOVEMENT SINCE THEY
RAIDED YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW'S
HOME?
LARA: IT'S BEEN ELEVATED TO THE
LEVEL OF THE SUPREME COURT AT
THIS POINT BY MY FATHER-IN-LAW'S
TEAM BECAUSE HE WANTS
TRANSPARENCY AND PEOPLE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT ALL
AMERICANS SHOULD WANT AND ON ALL
ACCOUNTS, NO MATTER WHO THE
INDIVIDUAL IS, BUT, SEAN, I'M
GLAD YOU SAID THAT THAT NOBODY
WANTS -- I CAN SAY THIS AS A
MEMBER OF A FORMER FIRST FAMILY,
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE WHEN THE
FAMILY OF A PRESIDENT OR SOMEONE
IN A MAJOR POSITION IS TARGETED.
I THINK THAT'S ALWAYS A BAD
THING AND IT'S TERRIBLE TO SEE
THE DIFFERENCE HERE AS YOU POINT
OUT IS THAT HUNTER BIDEN IS TIED
DIRECTLY TO JOE BIDEN AS THE BIG
GUY AND THERE'S CHINA AND
THERE'S RUSSIA AND THERE'S
UKRAINE AND THERE ARE MAJOR
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE AS
AMERICAN CITIZENS IS OUR
PRESIDENT COMPROMISED AND NO ONE
HAS BEEN ABLE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
LARA: TO THAT POINT, LEST --
GIANNO: TO THAT POINT, LET'S
PLAY JIM JORDAN.
>> IN 2016 THEY SPIED ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
IN 2018 IT WAS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, IN 2020 THEY
SUPPRESSED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP AND NOW IN
2020 THEY'VE RAIDED THE HOME OF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, TAKEN THE
PHONE OF SITTING MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, 91 DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION SO WHEN IT THE FBI NOT
GOING TO INVOLVE THEMSELVES IN
ONE OF OUR ELECTIONS?
THAT'S PROBABLY KEY QUESTION.
WE'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HOLD THESE FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE AND IF WE HAVE THE
MAJORITY BRING THEM IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS AND DO THE DEPOSITIONS
THAT NEED TO BE DONE TO GET THE
FACTS.
GIANNO: NOW, SEAN, THEY CAN DO
ALL THE HEARINGS THEY WANT BUT
THE FBI HAS TO STILL COOPERATE
THE IRS, ANY OF THESE OTHER
AGENCIES THEY HAVE TO COOPERATE
AND NOW UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
JOE BIDEN SO DO YOU THINK WE'RE
GOING TO REALLY GET SOMETHING
DONE IF REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE.
SEAN: REPUBLICANS WILL HOLD THE
MONEY BACK IF THEY DON'T COMPLY
WITH THE SUBPOENAS AND REQUEST
THE POWER OF THE PURSE BELONGS
IN CONGRESS AND HOLD PURSE BACK
AND CONGRESS AND MONEY SPEAKS IN
WASHINGTON AND GET COMPLIANCE AT
SOME POINT AND THEY'LL DRAG HER
FEET AND THIS IS GOING 234 AND
JOE BIDEN IS AFRAID HIMSELF.
THEY'RE AFRAID FOR POLITICAL
CAREER AND FUN AND MONEY SHE
MADE AND HIRE BIG PEOPLE A